a ride-sharing vehicle is to complete an
interstate trip totaling a thousand
kilometers at a constant speed of V
kilometers per hour and you're like well
I haven't even got started the question
there's a lot to take in so can I just
make a suggestion which is for all
questions that are a bit like this where
it's like there's a paragraph sometimes
in the HSC it'll be like an entire page
right because of many parts the first
important thing to do before we begin
solving anything is to note down the
information that we think is important
so I just read the first sentence what
stands out to you as the essential
information that we need to take note of
religious power okay fantastic so what
would you write down for that one
two
um the consumption rate of the fuel so
let's write that down this is the the
car consumes fuel at the rate of so this
is fuel
consumption
and by the way even though
it may seem a little bit like oh man can
we avoid writing so many words there's
going to be a lot of equations flying
around so it's super important that as
we write things down we know what it is
they refer to so I've got six plus v
squared on 50 is that right
and then the unit is liters per hour
okay now before we um move off of this
can I actually just rewind a step go
back to our very first sentence there's
some information in there that's also
important which it's not in the form of
an equation but it still matters what
can you see in that first sentence
that's important
okay fantastic so I've got a constant
speed that the um what's traveling it's
a it's a vehicle a car I guess um so
constant speed and you just said it was
V kilometers per hour is there anything
else essential in that first sentence
it's like a number right
good so this is the total Journey so a
thousand kilometers so I'll say
um total Journey
okay now the thing that we're doing at
the moment um fancy name for it it's
called
mathematizing so like you said there's
all these like sentences and words but
we're trying to draw out what are the
important bits and pieces okay
uh then it says it starts like we
haven't even got to a question yet right
it says as a bonus the company has
offered to pay and then there's all this
stuff here right so this is to do with
how much the person is going to earn
like this is this is how much fuel
they're using but then presumably
they're actually going to make some
money off of this journey right so
there's a lot there I'm going to read it
and then you tell me which you think is
important right as a bonus the company's
offered to pay
50 cents per liter for fueling for
safety
two drivers uh where they will each be
paid 45 dollars per hour whilst they are
completing the trip okay so
um there's two piece of information
there right so one of them is per liter
This Is 50 cents per liter so we'll sort
of write that down as a um it's a fuel
uh it's like a rebate I suppose they're
like you're spending money
on your fuel we'll pay you back a little
bit for the fuel okay now by the way I'm
going to call this like the fuel rebate
I guess
um it's 56 cents per watt
um yeah very good 50 cents per liter by
the way just on that I don't know how
old this question is but does that seem
like it's going to cover all of it do
you know much about fuel costs it's not
even close right um I actually just
filled up my petrol today and it was
like a dollar ninety or something
ridiculous but anyway at least it's a
little bit and then the other thing that
they get paid is is not a per liter cost
it's a dollars per watt very good so
this is forty five dollars per hour so
this is kind of like a hmm what would we
call this so it's like the driver's fee
I guess
what did we just say 45 dollars per
is that all right
okay fantastic now
there's a lot even just on here right
and by the way don't feel bad if this is
a question that challenged you right
part of what is challenging about this
is not only do you have lots of
different piece information but the
rates that you've got here right you've
got dollars per hour
you've got cents per liter liters per
hour
and then kilometers per hour so these
rates will interact with each other but
not a single one of them is actually the
same do you see that so there's a lot in
there so don't feel bad that it's
confusing okay
then it says let's see represent total
cost so C for cost
of fuel and the driver's wages for the
trip okay so let's just write that down
so C equals
cost of fuel
plus what was the other thing
um
the driver's wages
Okay now what's what's nice about this
part is that there is actually a result
given to us so we need to assemble all
of this stuff and then the result
they're going to get us to is this C
equals all right you can see the result
there it's 10 V
plus is that 93 000. 93 000 overview
very good
if the company was to pay for two
drivers actually I'll just stay with
that color right there
okay
now let's have a look at it for a minute
when you have a look at this question
here right or rather at this result that
we're trying to get to right are there
any clues at all that you can see which
sort of connect you to this are there
any bits that you like say oh I can I
can relate that or does it all seem like
there's not really any connection what
do you reckon
so you're like oh good the V I know
where that's going to come in very good
okay what else can you see
mm-hmm
so I know that I've got this V here
right and then the fuel consumption rate
you can see it also has V's in it right
so I'm going to do some substitution of
this and that's going to end up with
like when they all come together that
will give me some of the fees that are
here okay uh what about this driver's
fee it's 45 dollars per hour where do
you think that's going to fit in
and there are let's have a look it
actually shares they will each be paid
45 so in fact this is going to be each
so this gets doubled right because
there's two drivers
okay so it's really important to know
right
okay so now what we need to try and do
is combine if you have a look at this
right can you see that this costs
because it's totally to do with v this
right I need to try and get all the
other bits and pieces out of the way so
for example I'm like oh okay I want to
drive as fit it's gonna be 45 per hour
but I don't know how many hours it's
going to take you can can you see
there's no thing here that says What's
the total number of hours for the
journey so I kind of have to work that
out so let's actually start to piece
that together right
so for example if I consider total
hours
so now this is me trying to work through
some of the information that I've got
here okay so where Debbie and I uh left
off was we want to get to this
by trying to assemble all of this
information and part of what's hard
about this question is number one it's
just heaps information number two it's
all of different
what's the word I'm looking for you guys
know when you first met sirs do you
remember that in your nine you're like
irrational numbers right if you had
something like a root 3 and a root 5 and
a root 2 in an equation none of them
talk to each other right you've got to
do things to them in order to have them
like collected like terms and so on and
that's exactly what you've got here but
in calculus terms all the rates are
talking different languages columns per
hour liters per hour cents per liter
dollars per hour it's all the jumble
okay all right so at the moment we're
doing our rati was this cost is going to
have something to do with how many hours
they've been driving but we don't even
know like it doesn't tell us how long
they drive for but we can work it out
have a think about this right suppose I
told you that they did a thousand
Commodities as a total Journey
but they did it
at 50 kilometers per hour so this is an
actual speed now you guys could tell me
how long that Journey would take right
you can use a calculator if you like but
I've chosen an easy number how long is
that going to take
20 hours 20 hours yeah what's your name
sorry a g Hajime how did you get 20.
100 divided by 50.
1000 divided by 50. the answer was
correct right so a thousand kilometers
at that rate 20 hours now that's easy
because like it's an actual number I
don't have an actual number but the
process is the same so instead of saying
a thousand divided by 20 I'm just going
to go a thousand divided by what
me because that can change right now
just pause for a minute do you see this
is a good sign right because this over V
here like where did that come from it
came from here and came from us saying
if I want to know how long this takes
I'm gonna have to do a division of some
kind so far so good